quand même n'a fait remarquer j'avais
des tic et des tremblements nerveux
jusqu'à présent fatigue importante perte
de connaissance difficultés pour parler
voilà des symptômes physiques et
psychologiques dans une situation de
burn out
j'ai rencontré un cas d'une salariée qui
a dû réapprendre à lire a écrit qu à
écrire tellement ses neurones avaient
été détruits parle parle uggla cortisol
qui est un produit qui est un produit
qui est générée par le stress qui
détruit les neurones dans les yvelines
le phénomène est en nette augmentation
ce sont les chiffres qui ont été avancés
par une deux intervenantes de la maison
souffrance au travail qui s installe à
poissy la première année de création en
ils ont eu 800 personnes deuxième année
3000 personnes sont venus les voir et la
quatrième la troisième année par dont
11000 personnes sont venus les voir
à 54 ans daniel le meunier travail dans
une multinationale
après une restructuration elle est
contrainte d'occuper le poste de chargé
de voyages problème elle n'avait pas les
compétences pour cet emploi et a subi
une surcharge de travail
je m'étais dit dans le temps pires que
j'ai pas le choix
l'entreprise je l'aimais
et j'ai envie de donner encore et de
prouver que je peux faire encore autre
chose de nouveau et ça n'a pas fait
parce que j'avais perdu le sommeil parce
que j'avais perdu l'appétit parce que
j'avais perdu confiance en moi confiance
en entreprise je suis certainement le
burn out est arrivé parce qu'il y avait
cette surcharge de travail
daniel a été arrêté en mai 2014
mon système nerveux et a été adapté est
abîmée j'ai un traitement lourd nous et
je sais que je vais pas retrouvé ma
santé je sais et mais je le chat ça
c'est important pour moi c'est ma
thérapie c'est mieux qu'un médicament
engagement important dans son emploi
difficultés économiques de l'entreprise
et le travail à la maison
les causes du burn out sont multiples ce
sujet pourrait émerger dans les débats
politiques